rare bipartisanship on the same issue
about china and human rights on the
house floor let's bring in florida
republican senator marco rubio who sits
on the intelligence and for foreign
relations committee senator thanks for
being here
what about what's being done uh when it
comes to china and the olympics uh is it
enough in your mind and what should be
done
well there's two things at play here
obviously the first is doing the right
thing right i mean calling these things
out should matter irrespective of how
powerful that country is or how
important they are geopolitically but
the other thing that there's evidence of
here that's pretty clear is how
dependent our economy has become on
china when i say our economy it's the
things we buy at stores but it's also
our corporations i mean we've got large
very influential powerful organizations
in our country in the business sector
who rely on the access to the chinese
market and production in china for their
bottom line i mean it is it is for them
too valuable now to jeopardize and i
think that's true for the national
basketball association i think that's
been true for for nike for apple and a
host of others and that includes i
imagine nbc as well with the coverage of
the olympic games i mean if their
coverage gets out of line they could
very well be barred from sending
journalists there to cover an athletic
competition so i think that what we're
seeing here is evidence that of how
deeply intertwined their they become in
our economy and how much control it
gives them over what we get to see watch
by how much we pay for things and what
our companies are willing to say
you know in a speech you delivered today
you referenced bill clinton making this
statement back in 2000 about pushing for
china to be a part of the wto take a
listen
we have a far greater chance of having a
positive influence on china's actions
if we welcome china into the world
community
instead of shutting it out by joining
the wto china is not simply agreeing to
import more of our products
it is agreeing to import one of
democracy's most cherished values
economic freedom
you called that silly and wrong is that
correct yeah i think in 20 years of
hindsight that that i believe that
speech was about 20 years ago this very
week
i think when you listen to those words
now they that's actually not what's
happened what we've done is we've
exported jobs we've sent american jobs
american manufacturing capability we
exported that to china china took it
they made our companies dependent in
many cases they actually you know stole
the secrets of those companies and now
those companies are no longer there
because they're doing it instead and
they've made us incredibly dependent on
them to produce all kinds of things that
we now rely on including to defend our
country they've also become a place now
where you know we have a
finance market now a stock market in
wall street where you've got major
american investment funds that are
investing in companies that are
developing weapons that will one day
potentially be designed and aimed to
kill
american service men and women and
that's been the outcome of the last 20
years it was a bad decision based on
flawed assumptions and now we're seeing
the consequences of it
is there a responsibility for lawmakers
to be talking to these companies or to
the nba or to others who
they feel are doing the wrong things by
interacting and dealing with china
i think there is i think that's what's
happening but ultimately you have to
understand that these all these
companies that are publicly traded they
have quarterly reports and if they
kicked out of china they get kicked out
of china their profits are going to go
down their costs are going to go up and
they're going to have to answer to their
shareholders so they're basically now in
a trap a trap that creates a situation
in which we have american companies who
benefit from being here in the united
states and our laws and our in our
system
american companies who consistently
advocate now for policies or against
they advocate for policies that are good
for china and bad for america because of
what it would mean to their bottom line
so it's a very difficult situation to
unwind now but we have to we have no
choice this cannot continue on this
trend line or the world's going to look
very different 10 or 20 years from now
you think the buy administration is weak
on china i do and i think they're weak
on china because they're divided i think
there are some people that recognize
this threat and i think there are others
that are practitioners and believers and
the failed bipartisan consensus that
brought it to this point and then you've
got john kerry which is a breed unto
himself john kerry wants to do a climate
deal with china and he doesn't want to
say or do anything that forces or
creates a ruckus with the chinese
because he's hoping that his legacy in
life is going to be that he cut some
deal with the chinese on climate change
which by the way the chinese won't keep
because they don't keep any deal
that's bad for them
you know uh
candidate trump and then president trump
talked a lot about china um
do you think former president trump is
getting back in this race
i don't know you'll have to ask him i
mean i believe that if he runs he's
going to be the party's nominees the
most
well-known and popular republican among
republicans in the country i don't have
any ideas of what he's going to do and
he doesn't have to make that decision
now
but
for you you've mended ways after all the
uh
2016 back and forth
well yeah look i mean i i would tell
people that when president trump was
president united states i got a lot of
good things done for florida and for our
country we had a very good working
relationship and i i don't um at the end
of the day you know we didn't agree on
everything but he seemed to always
respect that i don't believe he said a
signal a negative word about me since
the day i stopped running for president
so we had a good working relationship
which is possible you know with people
you don't agree with 100 of the time but
i do give him a lot of credit on china i
mean the the orthodoxy the republican
party and much of our politics was not
what it is what was something very
different
and he challenged that as a candidate
and i think he deserves credit for it
senator marco rubio we appreciate your
time thanks thank you hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else